now to the latest on the mystery
surrounding those unidentified objects
in the sky three days in a row Friday
Saturday and Sunday the U.S military
shot down objects over Alaska Canada's
Yukon Territory and Lake Huron that's
after an American fighter jet destroyed
a Chinese spy balloon off the coast of
South Carolina more than a week ago so
what's going on here Ed O'Keefe is at
the White House looking for answers
what started off as just a Chinese spy
balloon shot down nine days ago they
just shot it is now a much broader
intelligence investigation with even
more flying objects taken out of the sky
the fourth manned object was shot down
by an F-16 over Lake Huron Sunday it was
first detected Saturday over Montana
U.S officials described it as an
octagonal structure with strings hanging
off and its path and altitude raised
concerns while it wasn't considered a
military threat the Pentagon says it had
potential surveillance capabilities and
a top General says they're considering
all options I'll let the Intel community
and the county
community
figured that out I
have there have now been three shoot
Downs in three days all since that
Chinese spyballoon was deflated off the
coast of South Carolina on Friday
President Biden ordered the shoot down
of an object off the northern coast of
Alaska taken down by an F-22 fighter jet
success
and on Saturday Canadian Prime Minister
Justin Trudeau ordered the shootdown of
an unidentified object spotted over
Canada's Yukon Territory Canadian and
American fighter jets were scrambled and
an American F-22 successfully shot down
the object
recovery teams are on the ground looking
to find and analyze the object what's
gone on the last you know two weeks or
so 10 days has been nothing short of
craziness now Democrats and Republicans
are pressing the Pentagon and
intelligence agencies for more details
the military needs to have a plan to not
only determine what's out there but
determine the dangers that go with it I
would prefer them to be trigger happy
than to be permissive but we're going to
have to see whether or not this is just
the administration trying to to change
headlines
we should learn a lot more about these
objects once the debris is recovered in
the coming days and we should also point
out since the shootdown of the Chinese
five balloon Radars have been enhanced
to better track these objects especially
those at lower altitudes which may
explain Tony why so many of them are
being shot down we'll also wait and see
whether President Biden himself has
anything more to say about all this
yeah a lot of waiting hope there's more
seeing in the future Ed O'Keefe thank
you very much